bonjour à tous
le g20 achève ses travaux
après la première session d'hier y est
donc une session aujourd'hui qui a été
largement consacré au
problème de la sortie de la crise
économique suscités par la pandémie
kohona virus
et donc des approches de lutte plus
coordonnées ont été traités et la
troisième session était consacrée
au développement durable dans le
contexte
des objectifs de développement durable
fixé par l'onu à l'horizon 2030 et la
conclusion principale que l'on peut
faire de ces travaux de ce sommet
et les travaux non seulement des leaders
mais des dirigeants mais également des
experts et qui travaille notamment sur
une déclaration commune c'est que les
tentatives de promouvoir des approches
unilatérale ne correspond pas à une
donnée et la plupart des participants se
sont dits que le g20 devait donner
l'exemple de la recherche de solutions
communes qui puisse assurer l'équilibré
des intérêts tant en mesure de le
contrôler le corps de younes comme dans
la lutte pour
la préservation de l'environnement de
vie et la sécurité en matière de
sécurité énergétique le g20 se
prononcera pour des solutions en matière
de politique énergétique visant à
assurer un équilibre des intérêts entre
les fournisseurs et les consommateurs
en ce qui concerne les changements
climatiques il y à la logique essentiel
correspondant à la corde paris sur le
climat
s'appuyent sur le caractère volontaire
des mesures entreprises par les pays en
matière de lutte contre les rejets dans
l'air et dans le respect des intérêts
économiques nationaux
je pense donc c'est un résultat positif
vous pourrez dès aujourd'hui prendre
connaissance de la déclaration au final
mais les tendances générales
que qui doivent être soutenus je pense
c'est le travail mené deux concernent
un jean s'est investie à la 6ème flotte
des usa a envoyé son destroyer en mer
noire est ce que la russie a été prévenu
de ces manoeuvres et comment pourrait-on
évoluer cette démarche côté américain
vous savez ici il s'agit non pas de
prévenir mais de respecter les normes
juridiques internationales et que quand
un navire se rapproche de payer il doit
respecter la convention de montreux
selon laquelle les pays
impliqués c'est à dire les pays dont le
pavillon figure sur les navires doit
informer les autorités turques et autant
que je sache ces mesures sont respectées
et nous faisons en sorte que ce soit
toujours le cas en tout cas dans
l'ensemble
cette
présentation débattent des pavillons et
des navires ce n'est pas un cas unique
on a eu plusieurs fois des situations où
les états unis l'avaient déclaré
ouvertement où il envoyait des navires
dans le but de contrer la russie de
limiter les risques vous provenant de la
russie c'est bien sûr un élément qui
n'ajoute pas la stabilité générale et
ses tentatives de provoquer les pays qui
sont ceux qui sur le pourtour de la mer
noire
cela constitue une politique
conflictuel
et donc
là
la roumanie la bulgarie créé débat sur
sur ces pays je ne pense pas que ce soit
des bonnes conditions de bon voisinage
en tout cas nous sommes prêts à répondre
à toute
menace il n'existe pas de problème pour
assurer la sécurité de la russie et la
sécurité dans la mer noire mais nous ne
nous prononçons toujours pour que des
projets de coopération et non pas des
projets de confrontation
et il ya une organisation c'est
l'organisme de la coopération de la mer
noire qui concerne non seulement les
pays
en bordure de la mer mais il ya d'autres
pays de l'union européenne et d'autres
encore et nous sommes pour que la
coopération et non pas l'augmentation
des tensions soit la base des relations
entre les pays dans cette partie dans
cette région agence interfax
cette semaine le vice ministre des
affaires étrangères iranien était à
moscou pour parler de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien hier les européens et
les américains on en parlait est-ce que
l'actualisation des contacts
dans ce domaine signifie que les parties
sont prêtes à relancer les négociations
autour du nucléaire iranien si les
contacts sont activées si les partis
veulent reprendre les accords bien sûr
cette discussion ne peut se faire que
telle qu'elle était avant et
approuvées par l'onu en 2015 et tout âge
où toute suppression à l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien doit être exclu on
s'était mis d'accord
si quelqu'un a renoncé aux accords il
faut revenir dans le respect des
conventions à salhab le mans validé
monsieur le ministre est ce qu'il ya des
signaux de la part de l'otan sur la
nécessité de relancer le dialogue est ce
que vous savez qui va représenter l'otan
à moscou
dont vous tout de suite votre deuxième
question si la première comme si la
réponse à la première était bonne et
nous n'avons pas d'information sur ce
que veut faire l'otan nous nous appuyons
sur les faits au les faits disent qu il
y a l'otan ne souhaite aucun aucune
coopération avec nous nous avions des
représentants
et l'opt en a fait qu à nous apprendre à
vivre à vouloir nous apprendre à vivre
et donc on parle de l'ukraine et s'est
donc il y avait cette propagande et ces
tensions et ces pressions exercées sur
la russie la question est close si
l'otan a une bonne raison de s'adresser
à nous
nous avons un ambassadeur en belgique
qui s'occupe de ces questions et le cas
échéant vous pouvez envoyer un signal
via des plants d'herbe
bonjour
je ne sais pas
est-ce qu'il ya le progrès sur la
reconnaissance mutuelle des certificats
de vaccination
puisque le président poutine on a parlé
est ce que il y aura des contacts entre
avec le président biden entre le
président biden président poutine vous
avez vu votre équivalent monsieur
blinken
vous pouvez parfaitement publier vos
questions dans la forme dans laquelle
vous l'exposer sur les vaccins vous
allez lire la déclaration
il est clair que les dirigeants
veulent une reconnaissance mutuelle des
systèmes de vaccination
sur
les vaccins lafitte présence physique je
ne vois pas ici
de problème
il ya beaucoup de dirigeants qui
soutiennent ce que le président a
déclaré je n'ai pas de signaux précis
concernant les volontés de blinken mais
aujourd'hui avec le président gbagbo
nous avons eu un entretien lors du
déjeuner voilà
non
je voudrais revenir sur ce sommet
pourquoi la russie
souscrit à la décision de
l'equilibre carbone en 2060
pourquoi croyez-vous
2050 croyez vous vraiment que ce soit un
nombre magique
je le sais vous avez posé la question
étant convaincu que
2050 n'est pas négociable
non mais 2050 c'était
ambition qui a été explorée exposé par
l'union européenne
est-ce que la formulation originale du
communiqué
non si c'était une ambition de l'union
européenne alors les autres pays ont
aussi le droit d'avoir des ambitions
qu'il s'agisse du communiqué nous
apprécions ce qui a été fait par la
présidence italienne pour
[Musique]
organiser dès ce matin très tôt des
négociations
et mettre en place une déclaration qui
circulent mais j'aurais préféré que la
le projet de déclaration nous soit
communiquée avant et la réponse
l'explication de le dire en privé c'est
que ensuite il faut d'abord
discuter du texte
et sait ce qu'est la déclaration
originale avait convaincu mais c'est pas
très poli d'utiliser ce processus de
négociation comme ça a été fait et
nous sommes convaincus que
l'union européenne les états unis ont
des ambitions
pour 2050 et ils établissent à comme la
vérité finale mais je pense qu'il faut
respecter aussi les autres membres non
seulement du sommet mais aussi de la
communauté internationale nous n'aimons
pas
suivre des ambitions vides et des
promesses de belles promesses
mais l'union européenne par exemple
veut travailler sur le gaz russe par
exemple on voit donc que nous allons
poursuivre cela nous allons
obtenir une neutralité carbone pas avant
2060 c'est notre engagement et nous
sommes orientés là dessus et j'essaie
d'être grecque mais personne n'a à
chercher à nous prouver que 2050 et est
bon pas bon
sur les négociations de baden est-ce que
je peux reposer une question